storyline number 16 for the 2019 season
focuses on the sixth overall pick in the
2019 draft he is Duke quarterback daniel
Jones Giants fans very upset when the
team made the call at six instead of at
17 because there's a belief they could
have waited until that second of what
ultimately was three first-round picks
for the Giants because they traded back
into the bottom of the round that second
pick that pick number 17 could have been
Jones instead of pick number six they
could have gone with a pass rusher like
Josh Allen at number six instead of
allowing him to stay on the board for
the Jaguars at number seven so plenty of
criticism of the way that Jones arrived
now the question is when will he play we
have heard about the Kansas City model
being a possibility for the Giants with
the rookie sitting for the entire season
while Eli Manning gets one more year as
a starter like Alex Smith did a couple
of years ago in Kansas City when Patrick
mahomes arrived as the 10th overall pick
there's also been referenced to the
Green Bay model where Aaron Rodgers sat
for three years before he became the
starter that's a stretch though in New
York then there's the New York model
where Eli Manning became the starter
during his rookie season even though
Kurt Warner the starter as of week one
was five and four at the time Eli took
over one possibility that I refuse to
yield on is the one that has Daniel
Jones being the starter week one and I'm
not ready to rule that out especially
based upon some of the things we heard
from coach Pat Shermer late in the
offseason program suggesting that there
will be some sort of a competition
emphasizing and reiterating that Jones
is getting ready to play Shermer said
that he I'm Manning is getting ready to
have a great season and Jones is getting
ready to play and Shermer made it clear
that was this point the question is when
will Jones be ready to play when will
they put him on the field when will they
feel comfortable flipping the switch
from Eli Manning to daniel Jones a lot
of factors go into that but the ultimate
factor is this who gives the team the
best chance to win and the point that
I've been making all along is a simple
one if Jones really is good enough to
justify the sixth overall pick in the
draft he should be better than Eli
Manning otherwise you don't make Jones
the sixth overall pick in the draft you
take your chances on him being their
number
17 or later but if he truly is good
enough to be taken after only five other
guys in this year's draft
he should be good enough to beat out Eli
Manning based on where Manning currently
is if there is a fair head-to-head a
competition between the two players at
training camp we'll see how much of a
competition there is for now Eli Manning
is the starter but it's still at least
two months until the Giants will be
starting the season with one of those
two quarterbacks under Center still a
chance it's going to be Daniel Jones
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports